how's it going over there with fillers
partner good morning good morning hey
guys hey team my name is Alan I'm here
to make sure that nobody falls asleep so
that we could accurately assess the
effects of sleep deprivation this
experiment is gonna be fun we will get
started right now great ok afternoon low
let's pick it up so this is an art
competition and the winner gets to go
home at 6 o'clock that's right yeah 30
minutes
maybe it's a friend of ship no all right
David where are you at out of nowhere
comes sy lure the destroyer with laser
eye ball he approaches and rampages
Allan you defeat Sylar David wins you
didn't even leave mine yeah I'm gonna go
home and get some sleep
feeling bad for you right now not really
hi Wow
I just became a champion destiny walked
up and said are you a champion and I
said yes I am a champion
feeling good in three let's go I miss
you I'm gonna be coming home later okay
I have to work all day can I get a kiss
sleep deprivation affects my emotions
the most I mean like irritability is
skyrocketing crunching numbers and data
analytics it requires your brain to be
active all the time you know my brain
stopped functioning at midnight if I
screw up on a number here and I have no
idea where I screwed up how am I gonna
go back and try to retract everything
with my brain basically not working
I got a good one here check it out
hello please be a dear and remove this
Cup don't think anybody can be that
creative when they're sleepy and tired
and angry
why I'm the most tired that I've ever
been feel like my body is breaking down
what do you see on the screen
Oh a friend
two friends got nothing my happy so
happy so I'm gonna scare everybody with
this bunny costume ones and zeros ones
and zeros alright guys we made it you
know it looks like this 24-hour
experiment was not successful in fact
got one of these guys that's the one on
guys hey I feel refreshed let's get to
work
this was a foolhardy endeavor but I
think we all learned something put all
your effort in during those eight hours
and go home and have fun with your
friends or family why did I do this